Welcome back everyone this is the way this is
going to be my first mandalorian season 3 video
and top 10 wtf predictions now that we know way
more about what's going on with the characters
next not just the mandalorian din djarin and grogu
but all the other side characters too after the
events of the book of boba fett finale if you're
new to the channel i will be doing videos for
all the star wars episodes this year obi-wan
kenobi are the next episodes we're getting
in may so hello there we have the rogue one
prequel episodes and then the mandalorian
season three episodes will start by the end of
the year about the same time that the book of
boba fett episode started just blanket spoiler
warning for everything that just happened on the
book of boba fett if you have not watched those
episodes yet but we got a little teaser for the
mandalorian season 3 at the end of that for what
mando and grogu are going to be doing obviously
he modified that naboo n1 star fighter there's
a little grogu sidespot in it and they have that
funny moment of him tapping on the glass to get
him to punch the accelerator over and over again
but i think it's pretty easy to assume that
eventually they will get a bigger starship
like if they're going to be pulling jobs again
together amanda will be doing some more bounty
hunting to earn money along the way he'll have to
eventually get a bigger ship but he'll probably
still be flying that star fighter at least at the
beginning of the mandalorian season three and if
it wasn't clear they were also trying to tell you
with this scene that the events of the mandalorian
season 3 episode 1 will pick up pretty closely
right after the events of this scene right here
but top 10 wtf predictions number 10 obviously
we have to start with grogu and luke skywalker
saying that grogu will not not leave mando
again to go back to become a jedi training
under luke skywalker at his brand new temple on
a planet that lucasfilm still has not named yet
no reference to what planet this is in any of the
material anywhere in star wars yet grogu left luke
skywalker during the book of boba fett choosing
to go back to the mandalorian and per luke
skywalker's test the way he explained it to grogu
making him choose between the mandalorian armor
yoda's lightsaber if he chose the armor he would
be forsaking the jedi path that luke skywalker
was laying out for him so literally at the end of
the mandalorian season 2 after leaving mando then
coming right back to mando during the book of boba
fett after a short time jump they're not gonna
again just have him turn right back around and go
back to luke skywalker also bringing him back to
mando was practically a move that jon favreau and
dave filoni made because grogu and mando together
are the show that's the mandalorian so number
nine the yodalorian as i've said before they'll
continue to pay off the concept that the title
of the show the mandalorian is also meant to be
a reference to grosgu not just din djarin like all
through the mandalorian season 1 season 2 even the
book of boba fett episodes with the little tiny
mandalorian armor they kept referencing foundlings
children from other cultures that mandalorians
would rescue take into their culture and they
would become mandos themselves as a mandalorian
foundling he should have this it's his right
din djarin was a foundling grogu became a
foundling the armorer even told mando back
in season one that there are clan of two now mando
being like rogue's new father and that's how they
played their dynamic through all these seasons
and episodes grogu in choosing the mandalorian
armor wearing the armor is his way of saying
that he is a mandalorian too i think it would
be too on the nose for him to literally say this
is the way with his tiny little mouth if he could
speak as well as other members of his species like
yoda he would also probably say it out loud though
number eight even though grogu chose the armor
over yoda's lightsaber forsakes the traditional
jedi path that luke skywalker was offering him
he will still continue to train in the force
deep in his connection to the force he'll just
be following his own path like ahsoka tano ahsoka
tano is not a jedi she left the jedi order but she
continued to deepen her connection with the force
that's also why they wrote that scene of luke
skywalker who was standing right next to ahsoka
when he was talking about it saying that he wasn't
so much teaching grogu new force abilities as much
as he was helping him remember his previous
training at the jedi temple on coruscant
before order 66 he was unlocking grogu's hidden
memories jedi knowledge that he suppressed in
order to save himself from the emperor darth vader
jedi hunters the inquisitors so grogu will just
continue to remember things as he's traveling with
mando having adventures bit by bit and we'll just
see him use a lot of the force abilities that he
and luke skywalker practice in more complex ways
like in the book of boba fett finale they paid
off the yoda size matters not speech that luke
skywalker gave him when he calmed down the rancor
number seven speaking of ahsoka tano she will come
back again for another cameo scene and she'll
eventually meet up with luke skywalker again in
the distant future not during the mandalorian
season three her showing up during the book of
boba fett episode just paid off one of my huge
predictions after the mandalorian season too
she left at the end of her episode to continue her
mission to find grand admiral thrawn ezra bridger
with sabine wren but the whole idea was that after
they confirmed the series would be using luke
skywalker as a major character like we saw ahsoka
come back before we knew that luke skywalker was
coming back after he did we were all just waiting
for some ahsoka tano luke skywalker scenes
together because canonically they never actually
met in person up to that point in the timeline
when she left luke skywalker at the end of the
episode and said perhaps they'd see each other
again that was dave filoni john favreau saying
yes definitely they'll have more scenes together
in the future just not right away i do not expect
luke skywalker to show up in a cameo scene during
mando season 3. i was even blown away that they
brought him back during the book of boba fett but
they did that to pay off all the grogu jedi temple
training scenes that's also why they did not bring
him back in the finale like okay we did that we
did our luke skywalker cameo scene we don't need
to do that again when ahsoka left though she just
left to continue her mission to find grand admiral
thrawn and when she crosses paths again with
mandu and grogu during the mandalorian season 3
she'll still be on that mission but probably just
briefly help mando and grogu with whatever problem
they're dealing with at the moment ahsoka just in
general in the star wars universe in this part of
the timeline is sort of like the sage obi-wan
kenobi figure of the series the wise and older
force user who can answer most of their questions
or tell them where to get answers that she herself
can't answer directly and just for reference even
though obviously ahsoka seems older she isn't that
old she's in her 40s during present day of the
series she's just a few years older than din
djarin himself given how young he was during
the events of the clone wars and the prequels
number six despite featuring yoda's lightsaber
and referencing so many yoda moments during the
book of boba fett they probably will not have
any actual yoda force ghost cameo scenes during
the mandalorian season 3. i think that if forced
ghost yoda ever does speak to grogu directly or
appear to grogu they would probably save something
like that for the very end of the series grogu
was even a little confused when luke skywalker
asked him if he remembered yoda from the jedi
temple on coruscant and even though there's all
these theories about yoda secretly being grogu's
father because members of their species are so
rare grogu would have had to have encountered
yoda at the jedi temple at some point in his early
life there long before order 66. the reason why he
probably couldn't remember yoda immediately here
is probably just because of all those suppressed
memories that luke was helping unlock so he could
always continue to remember things about yoda in
flashbacks as part of his training and as per the
book of boba fett finale grogu did not have yoda's
lightsaber so i think that stayed with luke
skywalker at the jedi temple number four the
mandalorian din djarin will continue training with
the darksaber to make more lightsaber references
training in lightsaber combat he'll probably
wind up fighting another mandalorian or someone
else who wants the actual darksaber or wants to
take it from him like he fought jon favreau's
past vizsla for the darksaber recently that'll
continue to happen people challenging him along
the way while he continues to get better wielding
the darksaber he'll also learn how to control his
emotions while using the darksaber in some jedi
techniques for lightsaber combat the reason why
the blade gets heavier when people wield it
is because all the lightsaber crystals inside
the blade absorb the wielder's emotions like they
flow through the lightsaber itself so the heavier
the emotions the darker the emotions the heavier
the blade becomes like the metaphorical baggage
that each wielder brings with them literally turns
into actual baggage making the dark saber heavier
so amanda will have to learn some classic jedi
techniques like letting go of his emotions while
fighting with it number three bogatan will
come back and they'll continue her storyline
of stealing more ships from the remnants of the
empire in her bid to retake the planet mandalore
mando will continue to help her when she
shows up but overall jon favreau and dave
filoni the other actors have said that the
mandalorian season 3 is meant to be more like
the mandalorian season 1 in terms of structure
and tone more so than what they did during the
mandalorian season 2 with all the characters
the difference between season 1 and season 2
is that season 1 was more about him going around
pulling bounty hunting jobs to keep grogu alive
season two was more about finding the jedi luke
skywalker and getting grogu to the jedi academy
so that just means that season three will be
more about mando and grogu's adventures together
episode to episode pulling jobs and occasionally
helping the other major side characters who show
up like boca tan ahsoka any other huge characters
that they bring back and yes most of the boba fett
characters will come back too like boba fett
himself will come back during mando season 3.
number two speaking of other huge characters
sabine wren will probably be one of the next
big characters that they introduced during season
3 as part of ahsokitano's storyline they confirmed
that they cast a sabine actress for the ahsoka
series but they won't actually be filming that
for a little while so i think the reason why they
did that so early is because they announced her
right before they started filming the mandalorian
season 3 because they probably plan to debut her
in a cameo scene during the mandalorian season 3
episodes and she'll just show up as part of the
sokatano's storyline their storyline during the
mandalorian that they'll continue to cover during
the actual ahsoka episodes when they start that
series next year is all about finding ezra bridger
and grand admiral thrawn it's sort of like a
continuation of the teas that they had at the end
of star wars rebels in that finale but as of the
events of mandalorian season 2 thrawn had returned
from the unknown regions meaning that ezra bridger
had also probably returned to but they didn't know
where he was probably somewhere else inside the
outer rim they have not confirmed who's playing
live-action ezra bridger yet but we'll probably
find out pretty soon in number one big prediction
also pretty easy one to make we'll probably get
our first actual live-action grand admiral thrawn
cameo scene towards the end of mandalorian season
3. to make a marvel reference thrawn is kind of
like the thanos of this part of the timeline in
the star wars universe they already confirmed that
all the mandalorian episodes and all the spin-off
series that they're doing will eventually build
up to a major avengers endgame style crossover
event in this part of the timeline and grand
admiral thrawn will be the main villain of that
we got the name drop during the mandalorian
season 2 the next tease in setting that up
would actually be seeing him on screen like
thanos showing up in the post-credits scene of
the first avengers movie in avengers age of ultron
fine i'll do it myself but make it star wars they
have not confirmed who's playing him yet in live
action but my early theory just because so many of
the clone wars and rebels animated characters and
actors are coming back as the live-action versions
like katie sackoff being a live-action bogatan
is that they'll just cast lars mikkelsen who did
the voice of thrawn during star wars rebels most
of you probably remember him from sherlock season
three his villain was a very thrawn like character
but post all your mandalorian season 3 predictions
in the comments below we might actually get some
obi-wan kenobi trailer footage of the super bowl
this weekend there are a few marvel trailers that
they're releasing whatever they wind up releasing
of course i'll do videos for all of it so make
sure you enable alerts for my channel so you
don't miss any of those everyone click here
for my full book of boba fett episode 7 finale
video and click here for my new marvel x-men
teaser video and easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe and this is the way!